in the sci-fi film the matrix human
civilization is trapped in a virtual
world created by machines a vast city
built out of nothing but computer code
this is the aquatic version of the
matrix created by neuroscientists in
Massachusetts - a zebrafish the
repeating lines are currents in a river
as the Lions fly pass the fish
frantically flicks its tail to counter
the current Florian angered and his team
at Harvard are using zebrafish and the
matrix to learn about the brain baby
zebrafish are tiny and transparent which
makes them ideal animal models at five
days old the baby fish is four
millimeters long it's brain holds just a
few hundred thousand neurons that's big
enough for complex behaviors but small
enough that you can see all of the
individual cells under a microscope to
watch the brain in action the
researchers used genetically engineered
fish whose neurons glow green when they
fire a technique called calcium imaging
first the team tried imaging the fish
while they were swimming freely but
their wiggling brains messed up the data
the matrix setup means the fish can be
paralyzed here two glass pipettes hold
the fish the other two pipettes are
plugged into bundles of motor neurons in
its tail when the projector is switched
on the fish tries to swim against the
virtual current it can't actually move
but its intention is recorded from the
activity of its motor neurons at the
same time the researchers watch to see
which areas of the brain light up to
test theories about how the brain adapts
to changes in the environment the
researchers can make the lines move
faster or slower in the brain they found
particular sets of neurons light up when
something unexpected happens like a
suddenly strong current this enables the
fish to adjust its movements a behavior
called motor adaptation last year the
team systematically zoomed in on
different parts of the brain until they
had tracked the activity of
all 300 thousand neurons as the fish
were fictive li swimming this is the
first whole brain picture in any living
animal with any luck the approach will
lead to new fundamental principles of
how brain circuits interact with one
another in every animal including us